hier soir à montréal laure manaudou a
confirmé sa force de caractère et sa
résistance physique à 19 ans elle s'est
offert le titre de championne du monde
du 400 m nage libre
une vraie performance quand on sait que
le macadam elle avait failli être
éliminé son entraîneur est pour beaucoup
dans cette performance christophe
duchiron fera une base i 9h30 ce matin à
montréal au lendemain du titre mondial
rien n'a changé l'or va s'échauffer
philippe lucas a les mâchoires serrées
le père fouettard et la boudeuse mine de
rien ça va leur faire six ans de vie
professionnelle et d'une certaine
manière six ans de vie commune avec des
hauts et des bas et à l'arrivée un
exceptionnel palmarès championne
d'europe championne du monde surtout
championne du monde la dalle
la victoire de laure manaudou c'est
d'abord l'histoire d'une métamorphose et
d'une quasi résurrection inquiétante le
matin en séries elle a survolé les trois
quarts de la course en finale et
résister dans les 50 derniers mètres où
retour de la japonaise shibata le matin
même notre championne du monde était au
bord des larmes après sa série raté et
c'est alors que philippe lucas fit son
métier d'entraîneur il lui parla du pays
le pays de la reconquête
je suis dit j'ai confiance en toi tu dis
que tu vas gagner je lui ai dit en furie
bien évidemment ça n'est pas philippe
lucas qui nage mais quand elle pointe
son bonnet de bain et son mètre 80 au
départ hier soir à montréal
il est clair que l'or doit beaucoup à
son entraîneur et à ses proches moi au
jour d'aujourd'hui je prends sur la plus
grande course au niveau à pression
mentale qu'elle calcule son importance
est telle sur le podium les yeux
mouillés par l'émotion
heureuse et soulagée elle craignait de
décevoir mais elle avait tant chanté
cette nageuse d'exception qui déteste la
défaite autant qu'elle adore la victoire
après course
les deux font la bise et dans la ville
deux font la paire l'entraîneur et la
nageuse au caractère bien trempé